I am sometimes twice a day  now you know across the series I've been  obsessed with scrambled eggs and 13  billion of download to the recipe but we  cannot change it up we're catching this  Alaskan king yes yes thanks  so go super quick so you got one hat for  each name sometimes twice a day  sometimes twice a day  change your hair twice a day seriously  depends on the weather  they've only maybe sunny I just want  seriously  so just literally like that but some a  little touch of cream so that lovely and  now a short Deena's you want to say  exactly that in such a song that's it  thank you little small bits  [Applause]  and then I'm gonna put that on the plate  flakes on top that has to be beautiful  alaskan scrambled eggs let me know in  the comments what you think of that  amazing scrambled egg dish and if you  missed uncharted trust me you can watch  it on the link below or on the NatGeo  app